[Musique]
Josiane est Dante familiale depuis 46
ans elle s'occupe de Béatrice sa fille
atteinte de trisomie
21 alors Béatrice
elle est née comme ça puisque elle est
triseomig 21 et bien entendu quand elle
est née puisque elle est née à la maison
je savais pas je croyais qu'elle était
chinoise ben oui parce que dans le temps
longtemps ça les gens ne sortaient pas
leur enfant comme ça et moi-même j'étais
loin dans la campagne bon personne
j'avais jamais vu et comme dans ma
famille il y a des Chinois je croyais
qu'elle était chinoise c'est tout et
puis bon ben moi j'ai vécu comme ça là
avec elle mais j'ai appris au bout de 8
jours seulement par mon médecin traitant
cette maman a fait le choix de s'occuper
chaque jour de sa fille sans jamais
penser à la placé en internat dans une
structure spécialisée avant il y avait
très peu de structure pourir garder ses
enfants et moi j'ai dit mon enfant je
pourrais l'élever mieux qu'un autre et
pourutant même quand je travaillais ben
elle partait à l'école ou bien elle
était dans un centre et ben je la
prenais après le centre ou bien le bus
là déposé
et ben voilà donc c'est pour ça que elle
est toujours à la maison elle est
toujours chez moi elle est avec moi pas
chez moi mais avec moi chaque matin
Béatrice attend le bus qui la conduit au
FAO ce foyer de vie propose aux adultes
handicapés des occupations quotidiennes
telles que des activités ludiques et
éducatives Béatrice ne raterait une
journée au centre pour rien au monde
attend son bus patiemment mais tout en
rou pétant apr le chauffeur ça parce que
pourquoi il est en retard il est
toujours en retard et il elle rpect tout
le temps elle a peu de manquer ce bus
parce qu'elle est trop contente d'aller
au FAO c'est c'est sa vie là-bas c'est
sa vie aussi hein pour elle elle a deux
maisons ici le matin et le soir et et le
weekend et là-bas à au faao bon ben
c'est c'est sa vie de l'école en quelque
sorte comme elle est ici bien elle va à
l'école elle est contente d'aller à
l'école et puis ça lui fait plaisir de
rencontrer les autres gens au lieu de
rester ici avec sa maman toute seule
aussi être aidant familial est souvent
éprouvant prendre du temps pour soi
devient difficile pourtant les moments
de répi sont essentiel tant pour
lesaidents que pour l'aider le Conseil
départemental a donc mis en place le
répiropo et le café des aidents des
temps de rencontres qui permettent
l'échange avec d'autres aidents mais
également avec des professionnels
Josiane est une adepte de ces dispositif
qui lui permettent de passer des moments
agréables dans une atmosphère
bienveillante ah ça c'est une chose
merveilleuse c'est une chose
que je crois que si je ne connaissais
pas ben il fallait il fallait apprendre
à connaître parce que ça c'est un lieu
de rencontre on rencontre les autres il
nous nous aide c'est les les les les
dames qui sont là là les personnes là
elle nous aide beaucoup hein elle nous
dit tout ce qu'il faut faire oui c'est
comme ça parce que c'est comme l'autre
mais elle nous aide beaucoup hein moi
j'ai j'ai beaucoup appris avec eux de
reprendre tout ça sur moi-même cette
maman courage donne à sa fille tout
l'amour dont elle a besoin pour Josiane
son enfant compte plus que tout au monde
je remercie le ciel de m'avoir donné cet
enfant aujourd'hui parce que que
aujourd'hui je vis pour elle et c'est
toute ma
[Musique]
vie